Paula Lehmann board house is a
complicated situation what's opening
they don't announce market goes in the
toilet we have to consider the
appropriate role of government here can
i as chairman of sec come forward are
like the gang that can't shoot straight
this is your job that was a clip from
the 2011 film too big to fail greed at
the highest levels of the corporate
world caused untold pain for millions of
Americans during and after the 2008
financial crisis and justice and similar
failures are the subject of a new book
with a title we can't fully say on air
let's call it the chicken bleep club why
the Justice Department fails to
prosecute executives it's published by
Simon & Schuster the vision of CBS we're
joined by the author Pulitzer Prize
winning journalist journalist Jesse
Eisenberg Jesse good morning good
morning thanks for having me let's talk
about the title to start with the title
we can't say but it comes actually from
something that was said I believe by by
James Comey the former FBI director in a
and former US Attorney exactly when
fifteen years ago when he became the US
attorney of the sudden Southern District
could gathered all of his criminal
prosecutors together and he gave him a
speech and these guys are the best of
the best and they think of themselves as
the best trial lawyers in the country
and he said how many of you have never
lost a case bunch of hands shoot up
because they're so proud of themselves
and he says me my buddies have a name
for you guys you are the chicken s club
what he meant was your jobs not about
winning it's about doing justice and
justice calls for taking on the most
powerful most ambitious cases so
sometimes you're gonna lose and don't be
afraid to lose sometimes you're gonna
lose and you have to sometimes you have
to lose to make a point when you talk
about some of the biggest case since
2003 is where things start with Enron
successful prosecution but you talk
about in the book that it taught the
wrong lesson explained that right so
they prosecute all the top executives of
Enron and all the accounting frauds of
that era but then they have faced a
backlash again from corporations and the
white-collar defense bar their lobbying
against their powers they say that
they're Cowboys and they internalize
that at the Department of Justice and
they become convinced that they've been
overly aggressive about prosecuting
corporate executives the
which is why you see I mean you saw in
the financial crisis few if any
prosecutions and I think only one top
corporate executive from one Bank Credit
Suisse was prosecuted so that I say
that's a big failure but I think it's
worse than that because it goes beyond
the banks and beyond the financial
crisis to major companies industrial
companies retailers tech pharmaceuticals
the Justice Department's lost the wheel
and ability to prosecute top corporate
executives in in in the case of the
financial crisis where there was a
public outcry and you had a public
demand in fact why did why didn't we see
prosecution it's shocking but they
really didn't look they didn't marshal
the resources and my argument is that
they've served focus on settling with
corporations for money yeah
rather than prosecuting individuals the
problem with that is it really
undermines the sense of justice in
America because you're not holding
people accountable and these guys
paychecks and it's not even the
executives paying checks it's the
shareholders right and then essentially
it becomes a business expense exactly
it's a cost of doing business and the
system is broken and this is the flip
side of inequality in America where we
prosecute to some people to aggressively
nonviolent drug criminals the poor
people of color and then we let other
people off rich powerful corporate
executives we did seek dodd-frank
legislation come out of the 2008
financial crisis but is that legislation
actually having any impact it has had a
modest impact I think it's inadequate
and the problem is one of the problems
is that it wasn't coupled with a
prosecutions so I think there was it
undermined legitimacy the prosecutor the
reforms there you know the banks are
safer than they used to be but now there
already is gonna be a rollback of that
legislation which is already inadequate
you talked about about 200 pages in you
refer to revolving doors between private
law firms in the Department of Justice
what happens there so the young
prosecutors in the Department of Justice
worked there for six or eight years
roughly and then they go almost all of
them go to representing corporations
yeah at major law firms in DC in New
York then they work for a number of
years and then they almost all come back
to the Department of Justice to be in
senior positions it's a revolving door
and the dirty little secret of corporate
law enforcement is that we have out
sourced and privatized it to these law
firms that recruit prosecutors yeah and
they also are it's it's as if we would
let Pablo Escobar hire a law firm in
Medellin to investigate whether he's a
drug dealer
Jesse eyes and girth thank you very much
interesting book interesting topic thank
you